what about Tommy Robinson do you guys
see what happened to him over the over
the past weekend he got arrested for no
reason he's sitting in a cafe eating
breakfast and they come in they say you
have to leave or or or else and and and
it's actually funny because he basically
says okay pay for my breakfast and they
go no and I'm like I actually kind of
think that's a reasonable position he
should not have to leave Tommy should be
like bro you're going to have to arrest
me and he and and he kind of did say
that but then eventually he goes okay
pay me back for my breakfast and I'm
like he's essentially saying fine I'll
leave give me my money back and they're
like we won't do it they won't even do
that I did think it was funny that in
the end Tommy was actually being
reasonable to their demands when he
didn't have to be MH but they said you
are what do they say that you're causing
harass you're the potential for alarm or
distress yeah so therefore you're not
he's he's in London and they said by
order of the city of London which is I
believe it's separate from London to
some degree it's like in the middle and
it's got different police or something
and uh they're like you have to leave or
else and it was an anti-Semitism March